hoy se cumplen cinco años desde que
entró en vigor el acuerdo de parís una
firma histórica que hoy un lustro
después sigue despertando muchas dudas
acerca de su viabilidad sin embargo en
el día dedicado a la energía la agencia
internacional de este sector aseguró que
los compromisos alcanzados hoy nos
permitirían mantener el aumento de las
temperaturas en 19 grados algo que si se
alinearía con el objetivo del documento
entre ellos el anuncio no vinculante que
ya se supo ayer sobre la reducción de
emisiones de metano en un 30% antes de
2030 aunque con notables ausencias como
los tres mayores emisores de este gas
china india y rusia hoy se reveló que
unos 40 países incluidos chile dejarán
de invertir en nuevas plantas de carbón
dentro y fuera de sus países y que
dejarán de usarlas para generación
eléctrica entre 2030 y 2040 estados
unidos y china- no se comprometieron a
este acuerdo pero sí a dejar de
financiar plantas de carbón en el
extranjero una promesa a la que se han
unido una veintena de países que
redirigirán los 8 mil millones de
dólares
invertir en este material a energías
renovables la pandemia de kobe 19
también está bien presente en la cop 26
y se han empezado a reportar algunos de
los primeros casos positivos aunque la
onu no ha querido confirmar cifras
exactas esto preocupa a quienes acuden a
esta conferencia en la que están
registradas 39 mil 500 personas lo que
la convierte en la de mayor
participación de la historia